let me ask you a fun question if uh
Hikaru and Nakamura was one of the two
people uh what I guess I apologize yeah
he could have he could have finished
second yeah so he lost the last round of
the candidates yeah and you uh put maybe
you can explain to me internet speed
copium is something he tweeted yeah but
if he if he got second would you uh
would you would you just despite him
still still play the world championship
that's internet question and when the
internet asks I must abide the Dude
abides yeah uh sure thank you internet
so after the last match uh I did an
interview
uh right after where I talked about the
fact that I was unlikely to play the
next one I'd spoken privately to both
family friends and of course also my
chess team that this was likely going to
be the last
the last match
um what happened was that right before
the world championship match there was
this young player alvareza firoza he had
a dramatic rise he rose to second in the
world rankings he was 18 then he's 19
now he qualified for the candidates and
it felt like there was like at least a
half realistic possibility that
he could be the Challenger for the next
World Championship uh and that sort of
lit a fire under me
um do you like that idea I like that I
like that a lot I love the idea of of
playing him in the next well world
championship and originally I just I was
sure that I wanted to announce right
after the tournament uh the match that
this was it I'm done I'm not playing the
next one
but this lit a fire under me so that
made me think you know
this actually motivates me and I just
wanted to get it out there for several
reasons to create more hype about the
candidates
to like sort of motivate myself a little
bit maybe motivate him
also obviously I wanted to give people
and people a heads up for the candidates
that
you might be playing for more than
more than first place like normally the
candidates is it's first place or best
it's like the world championship
um yeah and and then so Nakamura was one
of many people who just didn't believe
me which is fair because I've talked
before about not not necessarily wanting
to to defend again but I never like
talked as concretely or was as serious
as this time so he simply didn't believe
me and he was very vocal about that and
he said nobody believed me no no no the
players which may or may and not have
been true
and then yeah he lost he lost the last
game he didn't didn't qualify but to
answer the question no I'd already at
that point decided that I wouldn't
wouldn't play I would have liked it less
if he had
if he had not lost the last round but
the decision was but the decision was
already
um was already made does it uh does it
break your heart a little bit that
you're walking away from it in all the
ways that you mentioned that it's just
not fun there's a bunch of ways that it
doesn't seem to bring out the best kind
of chess
it doesn't bring out the best out of you
in the particular opponents involved
does it just break your heart a little
bit like you're walking away from
something or maybe the entire chess
Community is walking away from
a kind of a historic event
that was so important in the 20th
century at least
so I won the championship in 2013. I
said no to the candidates in 20
11 I didn't particularly like the format
I also wasn't I was just not in the mood
I didn't want the pressure
that was connected with the world
championship and I was perfectly content
at the time to play the tournaments that
I did play
um also to to be ranked number one in
the world I was comfortable with the
fact that I knew that I was
I was the best and I didn't need a title
to to show others um and what happened
later is
I suddenly decided to play
um in 2013 I liked they changed the
format I liked it better
um I just decided you know it could be
interesting let's try and get this
um there really wasn't more than more
than that to it it wasn't like fulfill
it fulfilling lifelong dream or anything
I just thought you know let's let's play
um so it's just a cool tournament yeah
it's a cool cool tournament it's a good
challenge you know
why not it's it's something that could
be a motivation it motivated me to get
in the in the best shape of my life that
had been till then so it was a good
thing uh and 2013 match brought me a lot
of a lot of joy as well so I'm very very
happy that I that I did that but I never
had any thoughts that I'm gonna like
keep the title for for a long time
immediately after the match in 2013 I I
mean also before the match I'd spoken
against
the fact that champion is seated into
the final which I thought was unfair
after the match I made a proposal that
we have a different system where the
champion doesn't have these Privileges
and people's reaction both players and
chess Community was General uh generally
like okay we're good we don't we don't
want that you keep your privileges I was
like okay whatever so you want to fight
for it every time yeah I want that